[موسيقى]
لذلك انا تحدثت يعني على الملف المياه
والدعم الكبير اللي شهدها هذا الملف خلال
هذه الفتره بعد تشكيل الحكومه من فخامه
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه من دوله رئيس
الوزراء وكذلك من معالي السيد وزير
الموارد معين لاهميه هذا الموضوع وتاثير
الكبير لذلك اليوم احنا عندما تحدثنا
وقلنا هنالك صفحه جديده في ملف التفاوض
نعم كل المتتبعين والمتابعين لهذا الموضوع
سيشهد هذا الدعم الكبير همم ملف التفاعل
هو ليس وليد اليوم ملف التفاوض منها عشرات
السنين لكن يعاني هذا الملف المد والجزر
ويعتمد ايضا بالتاكيد على جانب مهم وهو
جانب السياسي والاستقرار باعتبار انه كثير
من الطروحات التي قد يطرحها على سبيل
المثال الجانب التركي خصوصا خلال السنه
انه هذا الموضوع يبحث عندما يكون هنالك
مثلا استقرار امني او تكون يعني بعد تشكيل
الحكومه لذلك بعد تشكيل الحكومه فعلا صار
هنالك تحرك هنالك تواصل مع كل الاطراف من
اجل الاستمرار في هذا الملف
في ظل تكتم الحكومات العراقيه المتتاليه
خلال السنوات السابقه وبسبب قيام تركيا
وايران بقطع المياه وتغير المناخي وصل
العراق الى كارثه بيئيه وسنفته الامم
المتحده من بين اكثر خمس دول في العالم
تعرضت لتغير المناخيه الذي يسبب الجفاف
لا احنا مو نقدر نوصل احنا وصلنا للكارثه
البيئيه احنا على وعبرنا العتبه وعلى
ابواب هذه الكارثه البيئيه اذا استمر
الوضع المزري بهذا الشكل ااا المياه هي
الاساس لكل نظام بيئي كعلماء بيئه ما
يعرفون هذا الحقيقه بانه المياه هي اساس
القاعده البيئيه لكل التفاصيل ازاله
المياه تؤدي ايضا حتى الى اضطرابات سياسيه
بسبب التعلق المياه بالسلسله الايكولوجيه
لوصولا الى الاخر المستهلك وهم السكان
الاصليين او السكان المحليين اعطيك مثال
مثلا المياه الشحيحه تؤدي ايضا الى
تدمير التنوع البيولوجي اللي يسميه الايكو
سيستم سيلفيس او خدمات النظم الطبيعي اللي
سكان الاصلي معتمدين عليها صيد الاسماك
همم راعي الجاموس مثلا في مناطق الاهوار
سقي المزروعات كل هذا يعتمد على المياه
ازاله هذه المياه راح تؤدي الى تدمير
النظام البيئي فتصبح فرص العيش غير ملائمه
على ضفاف الانهار وبالتالي راح يضطر الناس
انه يها ديموغرافيه ويروحون الى مناطق
اكثر وفره بالمصادر